The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
mitopencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: In some ways, I won't
be able to compete with
live demonstrations of children
from last week.
But I will try to talk about
adult development.
And we will really sweep through
your minds and brains
from when you were not yet born
until you're going to be
in your '90s.
So here's your life from the
beginning to the end viewed in
different ways.
And we'll touch on a number
of different topics.
So you know this question about
people have talked for a
long time about the development
that one goes
throughout one's life.
What walks on four legs in the
morning, two legs in the
afternoon, three legs
in the evening?
You know the answer
to this, right?
People.
They're crawling, they're
standing up, and then
you get to my age.
And we need an extra little
prop to move around
successfully.
So sort of thinking about this,
that different things
matter to people at different
ages, that there's different
priorities, different
ways of thought.
Erik Erickson is often given
credit for trying to
articulate that.
And we'll just walk through
it for a moment.
Where he said at different
ages, at infancy, early
childhood, through school,
adolescence, young adulthood,
people are dealing with
different kinds of issues and
different developmental tasks
in front of them.
Your life is a constant
development.
Not maybe as dramatic as infancy
where we saw last time
that children really see
the world differently.
But there's different
challenges in front
of you at all ages.
At infancy, you're deciding
who can you
trust, who can you love.
Is it a good world?
And then the drama of potty
training, independence.
How much are you becoming a
free agent in the world?
Early school, where you start
to interact with other
children, and play, and make
friendships, and think about
social groups.
Later in schools, you're
becoming more advanced in
terms of what you're learning in
school and more complex in
terms of the social networks
that you're developing.
We'll come back to this at the
end, a period of high anxiety
and drama of adolescents.
Then there's something about
young adulthood.
You may have heard recently
people are speculating that
what used to be the beginning of
young adulthood culturally,
at least in the US, and maybe
Europe, and industrialized
parts of the world, that whereas
the '20s used to be
considered a decade of
adulthood, there are now
theories floating around or
impressions floating around
that '20s are the
new adolescence.
What are you guys think?
Everybody says, oh my '20s, I'm
going to discover this and
discover that.
But when I get to 30, that's
when we're playing for keeps.
Is it?
Well, and part of it's because
you live longer, on average.
Or you count on living longer.
And you do, on average,
live longer.
For a person who's counting on
living to 90, which many of
you are sort of, another decade
of finding your way,
your 20s, seems reasonable.
In a world where people didn't
live nearly as long, didn't
have as many options, by the
time you finished college--
or many people didn't go to
college-- it's roll up your
sleeves and get to adulthood.
So there's all these sort of
magazine discussions, are the
20s the new teens in terms of
whether people feel they have
responsibilities they have to
execute as a young adult.
And this a little bit timed
also, a little bit
anachronistic, then
having a family.
Although, I think we're much
more thinking about that's not
necessarily the root for
everybody at all.
And then old age where
you give other
people lots of advice.
So we're going to talk about
brain development from infancy
to young adulthood, cognitive
stability
and decline in adulthood.
We've talked a little
bit about that.
We'll talk a bit more.
Alterations in hemispheric
specializations
that come with aging.
A bunch of remarkable results
about exercise in the brain.
All of us want as we get older,
or just even when
you're younger maybe, just
a pill you pop and
you're ready to go.
That would be the best.
It turns out there's remarkable
evidence about what
physical exercise does
for the brain.
I'll share that with you--
especially in regards to
aging, but at all ages--
ideas about how as you get
older, your social and
emotional goals will tend to
change, a little bit about
rewards, and a little bit about
back to adolescence and
some thoughts about what's going
on in the adolescent
mind and brain.
So we know if there's one thing
about the brain that's
stunning, and challenging to
grasp, and empowers us to be
humans, it's this complexity.
There's a huge number of
neurons, fantastic number of
connections among the neurons.
So there's just a phenomenal
complexity that all starts
with a single cell.
And how does the brain
become this
dramatically complex organ?
And how does it organize in the
right way to let you be an
effective learner, an effective
partner in your
family, and so on?
So we start with the idea of
neurogenesis, a magical word,
the neurons being born.
And they have to make this
crawl, there's a huge path the
size of a neuron from the
ventricular surface, the
ventricle, the fluid-filled
space, to get to the place
you're going to be
in the brain.
It's a huge adventure
per neuron.
Cells dividing there, the
earliest neurons are existing
by the second embryonic week.
So that's when you began
to produce your
neurons in your brain.
By the seventh embryonic week--
so you're just two
months of pregnancy--
you're producing an estimated
500,000 neurons a minute.
We said the neuron is kind of
like a moderate computer.
Except unlike iPhones, it can't
keep track of where
you're going all the time.
We said it's a moderate
computer.
So 500,000 of those every
minute, I mean, staggering.
That it all works out
is staggering.
By the 18th week, you've mostly
made all the neurons
you're ever going to make for
the rest of your life except
in two brain regions.
And there's been a big debate
in the last decade about
another brain region.
I'll share those with you.
But people have been taught for
many, many, many years in
medical school, and college, and
graduate school, that all
the neurons you get are
by the 18th week.
So hang on to them
through healthy
living and wise behavior.
Because you have what
you have, right?
So don't lose them.
But we'll talk about that
you lose the vast
majority of them anyway.
I still recommend
healthy living.
Because you know, perhaps from
other courses, that the brain
does this wild thing.
It excessively overproduces, by
massive scales, the number
of neurons and the connections
among the neurons.
And then through use, it gets
rid of neurons and gets rid of
connections among neurons.
It's exactly the opposite way
if you build a building.
If you build a building,
what do you do?
You construct every bit of it
you need, and you're done.
Well you don't do is say, I
need a two-story building.
So I'm going to do a 40-story
building or a 90-story
building and then knock
off the stories
as they're not needed.
You say, well, that's wild.
Why would I do that?
But the brain brilliantly makes
many more neurons and
many more connections on epic
scales and then only uses the
ones that seem to be
useful for the
functions of the brain.
And so for that reason, the
density of the neurons in the
brain is much higher in a
two-year-old than in you,
where it was much higher when
you were two than it is now.
So in a two-year-old, they
have 55% more gray matter
density in the frontal
lobe than an adult.
Even at age five, even
at age seven,
they're 10% percent more.
From a peak of around before
birth, you're constantly
shedding neurons and their
connections and keeping the
ones that seem to be
effective somehow.
Now, for many years people said,
is there neurogenesis in
the adult brain?
Is everything you get before
you're born and
that's pretty much it?
And there's many reasons to
be interested in that.
One is just how does
the brain work?
How do people work?
The second is for diseases
like Alzheimer's disease,
Parkinson's disease,
and other diseases.
We would love to replace neurons
that have died to help
people do better.
So can the brain make new
neurons before birth?
There's compelling evidence in
animals, and some indirect
evidence in people too, that
neurogenesis does continue
into adulthood in the olfactory
bulb and in this
particular part-- and I'll come
back to this-- in the
hippocampus, a small part of
the hippocampus called the
dentate gyrus.
Everybody's in pretty much
agreement on this for the
moment, which is kind
of interesting.
Why those two areas amongst all
the areas in the brain?
What makes them different that
they can produce neurons all
throughout your life?
And then about a decade ago,
Elizabeth Gould at Princeton
said, oh, when I do the right
kind of experiment, I see new
neurons in the prefrontal cortex
of monkeys, and for
human primates.
That was a giant revolution.
Because they said,
wait a minute.
Maybe if monkeys are doing it,
people might be doing it,
making neurons throughout
their life.
We just did know that.
It's not so easy to measure.
If you think about it, the kind
of experiment to know for
certain if a human is making a
new neuron is not so easy.
Because brain imaging
is very far from the
single neuron level.
And even if we saw a neuron,
how could we tell it's new?
And then Pasko Rakic, a big
developmental researcher at
Yale said, that what she
really saw was glia.
The glia are the other cells in
the brain, not the neurons.
They support the neurons.
Everybody agrees that you make
glia all through your life.
There's no debate about that.
But glia are not the stuff
of thoughts and feelings.
Neurons are.
So what do we understand
about that whole story?
Here is an unbelievable
experiment, I think.
It's really not an experiment.
But it's a measurement.
Published in 2006, it's one
approach to asking, do adults
make new neurons?
So the nuclear bomb tests that
occur during the Cold War sent
a carbon-14 into the atmosphere
from 1955 to 1963
until there was an international
test ban treaty.
And then these decreased
and stopped.
But there was a lot of nuclear
bomb testing in the
late '50s and '60s.
That released carbon-14
into the atmosphere.
And that integrates with DNA and
forms a date mark for the
cell of a birth.
So this is not an experiment
we would want to do again,
atmospheric nuclear testing,
and having nuclear stuff
floating around in
the atmosphere.
I'll tell you the bottom line,
and I'll show you how they
figured this out.
What they figured out is looking
at people who died a
few years ago, that
nonneuronal cells are generated.
That was found before glial
cells are made throughout your
lifetime is the inference
from the finding.
But neurons are not generated
in adult neocortex.
The commentary in this article
said, no new neurons for you.
OK, that's not quite true.
We know these two little areas
in the brain do it but not in
most of the brain.
And they also looked at
something called BrdU,
B-R-D-U, which is another
way to take a
brain if you have it.
It marks newly synthesized
DNA.
So if you have the brain
directly to measure it, you
have a couple of measures of
newly synthesized DNA, which
would be the marker
of new neurons.
So here's a fantastically
interesting thing.
They took people who were born
in different times, took
postmortem samples, and measured
carbon-14 relative to
what was expected--
there's a line here-- it was
relative to what was expected
by the amount of carbon
in the atmosphere.
And here's what they found.
If they look for somebody born
after 1963, they have, in
their neurons, exactly the
amount that you would expect
if they made all their neurons
around here and the decrease
here didn't affect the
neurons at all.
The glia are here, which is kind
of an average of here and
the rest of life.
So if you measure the average
age of the glia, it was about
the average age of the life of
the person the carbon was
being picked up in the DNA,
because it's being made.
It's being kept,
and being made.
But the neurons all looked like
one value, the value that
has to do with when
you're born.
So it's not changing the number
of neurons that are
showing the carbon-14.
As if whatever you've got
at birth, that's it.
On the other hand, here is
somebody born before 1963,
having essentially zero carbon
that's being showing up in
their neuronal DNA, and having
again the expected average
glial DNA as if glia
kept going.
So this is fantastic.
It's looking at the carbon-14
in the DNA of neurons and
glial of people who
have passed away.
And saying the carbon-14 dating
looks like neurons.
You get them all before
you're born.
That's it.
Glia, you keep making.
And they can look at it more
directly by looking at this
thing that shows you recent
DNA, again, showing you
impressively that glia keep
making new glia with new DNA
but not new neurons.
So the current conclusion in the
field, as far as anybody
can tell, is no new neurons for
you except in your dentate
gyrus and olfactory bulb.
Now here's something
fantastic though.
It appears that exercise--
I'll just show you one example
in animals and humans--
there's evidence that exercise
will pump up the number of new
neurons you make in the
dentate gyrus of the
hippocampus.
And we know that the
hippocampus is
important for memory.
So that's not a bad place
to make new neurons.
So you know that going to
exercise will strengthen you
in various ways.
But you never realized, unless
you follow this line of work,
that when you exercise, you're
enhancing the number of new
neurons that you're producing
in your dentate gyrus.
So here's a couple ways people
have approached this.
So one way is to measure
cerebral blood volume, how
much blood is in the dentate.
And I'm going to show you
evidence that mice that are
allowed to exercise push
up the blood volume.
And that seems to go with
direct evidence of
neurogenesis.
Because you can do that
in the animals.
You can look up sacrificed
animals.
And then in humans, some
indirect evidence that
exercise is, again, pushing
up the blood volume in the
dentate and pushing up a little
bit of memory abilities
that go with the part
of the brain.
We can't go in and measure
neurons in the humans.
So here are mice who exercise
or didn't exercise.
They measured the
blood volume.
Here in red is the dentate
part of the hippocampus.
You can see it's the hottest
spot for blood volume.
And it's the only part that
responds to exercise.
So they had some mice
not get to exercise,
some mice get to exercise.
The blood volume increases
within the hippocampus
selectively in a small component
of the hippocampus,
the dentate gyrus.
Exercise is pushing up
the blood volume.
Now that's not direct evidence
about what's happening at the
cellular level.
But they can sacrifice these
animals and show you that if
you look at this binding that
goes with new neurons, with
new DNA, that's pushed up
the exercise animals.
Here's the statistics.
Here's the picture.
So in the animals, they can
correlate directly.
More blood volume and more new
neurons going with more
physical exercise.
In humans, they can measure
the blood volume.
And so they had some people do
more exercise, some people
less exercise.
Again, it was a dentate
gyrus selectively.
It showed an increase in
blood volume in humans.
And now they give them
a memory test.
And it's not overwhelming.
But at least in some cases, the
people who did exercising,
who pushed up their blood
volume, also pushed up a
little bit their memory
performance.
So in humans it has to be more
indirect, but all the data
aligned with the idea that
exercise is pushing up your
own neuronal genesis, the
creation of new neurons in one
of the two regions everybody
agrees we make new neurons,
the dentate gyrus and
the hippocampus.
But cells have to go incredible
distances at the
cellular size.
Neurons have to travel to
the intended location.
Migration occurs over many
months including eight months
postnatally.
Here's this neuron following
it's little path to where it's
going to go.
There's glial tracks following
molecular cues as to their
ultimate target location
to get organized.
Its initial destination and
function are predetermined at
the start of the migration.
People can measure things in
these that tell you where this
is going to end up.
It's programed in these cells.
Unless there's something that
blocks them, they know where
they're going to go and
make up different
parts of the brain.
And then they form synapses, the
part where information is
sent from one neuron
to another.
It occurs throughout the brain,
but at different rates
and different areas.
So very early, you see
it in spinal cord.
Very late, you see it in higher
cortical areas like
prefrontal cortex.
At the peak growth, there's an
estimate-- these are all gross
estimates--
that you may be forming 1.8
million synapses per second.
It's stunning, 1.8 million
synapses per second.
And do you know how many
molecules are in an average
synapse by current
estimations?
1,000.
There's 1,000 different
molecules in a synapse for it
to do it has to do.
Multiply that times 1.8
million per second.
It's spectacular biology.
And then they keep getting more
and more until two years.
And then you start
just losing them.
By age 16, you'll have
lost a lot of them.
And so the people have this
idea we mentioned before,
pruning and selection.
That we overgrow the number
of neurons, the number of
connections.
What stays is activity
dependence, or this use it or
lose it neural Darwinism.
Here's something amazing.
There's an estimate that we lose
20 billion synapses per
day through adolescence.
And that's not a bad thing.
That's not the worst behaving
adolescents doing the worst
things they can do.
That's the brain getting rid of
connections that aren't useful.
It's an incredibly interesting
way to
construct a powerful brain.
It's to get everybody
to way overbuild.
And then eliminate the ones that
aren't powerfully useful.
And another marker of
development is myelination.
That's the growth of the fatty
sheath that surrounds the
neurons that are extending
distances.
It insulates them and
accelerates their signal.
It looks like white matter
in the postmortem brain.
What happens through
adolescence--
here's age four to 22--
is that white matter goes up,
and gray matter goes down.
So quite interesting, the total
brain size from about
age six to about 20-- young
adulthood, most of you--
stays about the same, the
total brain size.
What you're doing is you're
getting rid of gray matter.
And you're enhancing
white matter.
You're getting rid of the
neurons that are nonproductive
and the synapses that
are nonproductive.
And you're increasing the
strength with which different
parts of the brain can
communicate with one another
through the white matter.
And so here's the kinds of
pictures of this growth.
And some of the parts of the
brain that mature latest by
these kinds of measures of
getting rid of the overgrowth,
are in prefrontal cortex.
And we've talked about
that before.
So many people are interested
always in thinking about
developmental issues and
the biology of them.
And here's a kind of
a stunning finding.
And we don't know exactly how
it would relate to humans.
But I thought it would be
interesting to share with you
and think about this
just a little bit.
So the title of the paper in
science was "Good Memories of
Bad Events in Infancy." So we
know from before, and just
common sense, that fear is
important for the survival.
So we start at the amygdala,
which seems essential for
learning what's to be feared.
Because what's to be feared is
what injures you, or worst
case, could kill you.
So the amygdala is essential
for learned fear.
And we know that one example, a
fear condition that depends
on the amygdala, would
be a neutral
stimulus like an odor--
odor that's not particularly
good or bad, just an odor--
and then a shock that makes
an aversive stimulus.
So you pair them through
conditioning, odor, shock,
odor, shock.
So the odor predicts
the shock.
Now, they looked at young rats
and looked at attachments.
And here's what they find
kind of remarkably.
Up to postnatal day nine for
these rats, if they were
exposed to the odors and the
shocks, here's what they do.
They know through pairings
odor, shock, odor, shock,
odor, shock, here
comes the odor.
Here comes the shock.
They still approach the odors.
That's what's in this graph.
Up to nine days, the
rats, the mice--
sorry--
are still approaching this odor
even though it will lead
to a shock.
But on the 10th day,
just one day later,
it completely reverses.
And they avoid the odors
that predict the
shock, a complete reversal.
So they keep going to the
odors with the shock.
And on the 10th today, the
pups stop going there.
And what they also
find is this.
If they look at metabolic
activity in the amygdala, for
the nine-day olds, it's the
same for the odor and the
shock, where a neutral order.
It's not selective to
what's to be feared.
And the 10-day old, here's a big
response in the amygdala
for the odor that predicts the
shock, for the fearful
learning, to know what's
scary, and
injurious and dangerous.
So how do people think
about this?
Well, this is an animal
experiment up to nine days.
We can't really know how
it relates to people.
But the speculation was this.
And maybe there's something
to it on a
different scale on people.
Why would an animal approach
something injurious, up to the
amygdala seems to get more
mature, and then
avoid what's injurious.
Why would that happen in such
a predictable evolutionary
determined way?
And the hypothesis is this.
That if you're a very helpless
newborn, you have to go to
things no matter what.
Because you're so dependent
on things in your
environment to survive.
But at some moment you mature
enough that you
say no thank you.
If it's going to be shocking
and painful, I'm
going to avoid it.
You become kind of independent
in that sense, in
the concrete sense.
And so the author said, well,
could it be helpful for
newborns to know, no matter
what, approach a caregiver,
not respond to things that are
negative, because you need the
care, because you're
so dependent.
And now this is super
speculatively.
A thing that's been noted is
that even in families where
there's unfortunate tremendous
abuse for a young child, the
abuse victims so commonly
remain powerful
loyal to their parents.
Is this kind of a mechanism that
mixes up attachment and
fear especially when you're
young and can't separate them
out so well?
So it's a huge leap from
the mice to the people.
But it's a mechanism that we
can understand might be
involved in how attachment
and fear can have unusual
relationships with
one another.
All right.
You can't avoid reading in the
newspapers, or seeing on your
computer screen, discussions
about the deficit and older
people like me demanding a lot
of medical care that's paid
for by the wages you're going
to get in a couple years.
I mean that's how
I look at it.
So you are entering a world,
we're all entering a world,
where the changing ages
demography of our society is
spectacular.
Japan is ahead of us in
this a little bit.
The rest of the world
is following.
And China is going to
be unbelievable when
it happens on scale.
But the United States right
now, right now.
And here's why.
For most of human history, the
average life expectancy was up
to 20 years old.
That's why you had
to be an adult.
Because at 20, who knows
how much time I have.
I better do my adult things.
Some people lived
for a long time.
This is really interesting.
It wasn't that everybody
perished by 30.
Some people lived to
60, 70, 80, 90.
But many people fell ill to
many diseases that are now
readily cured.
So the average age was 20.
In the 1800s, it became the
'30s, just a couple hundred
years ago in all of
human history.
By 2000, the average person
in the US lived until 77.
By 2010, 78.
So we're having a spectacular
growth in the proportion of
humans in our society who are
living a long, long time,
which is a wonderful thing.
But it's radically changing the
world we live in and the
world for those people who
are older as well.
So, for example, 100-year-old
people, there's 50,000 of them
in the US, which is triple what
there was a time ago.
And it's expected to be a
million people in the US who
are 100 years and older by
2050, which is in your
lifetime, a million people
in the US alone
will be 100 or older.
And maybe 50% of girls born in
2000 will live for a century.
Spectacular changes are
occurring right this moment.
The baby boom generation, huge
numbers of us are approaching
retirement and the kind of
medical support that gets
heavier when you get older on
average, huge numbers of us.
How's it changing?
One way it's changing is that
families often have-- and you
might hear this-- an issue of
families feeling that they're
a sandwich generation.
They're taking care of their
children and the elderly.
And you can bet if you have
parents who are living to 120,
you're doing that.
Giant effects on education,
pension, work, financial
markets, I mean these are
epic societal effects.
So you're hearing the discussion
now about how the
US is going to deal with this.
So there used to be kind
of an old model.
And even this is not that old.
This is from the mid-1950s.
Your job was to go to college,
have a career, have a mate,
take care of a kid, retire
at 65, and put your
feet up on the desk.
But all of a sudden, if
everybody's living--
not everybody, but huge numbers
of people are living--
until 70, 80, 90, 100, many in
pretty good health-- not
everybody we wish for-- but many
in pretty good health,
that's a fantastically
different thing.
65 is no longer the retirement
moment, and you're
glad you made it.
65 is something like the
halfway point of your
potential work life.
20 to 60, 60 to 100, something
like this.
It's an unbelievable change.
You cannot overestimate how it's
changing the world around
you, and how it will affect the
economics and the politics
of the world that the rest of us
will be in for many years.
There's about 10% of the
population over 65 now.
In 20 years, one out of every
four people will be over 65 by
current estimates.
So we're going to elect whatever
president we want.
And older people go vote a lot
more than younger people.
You can change that.
But that's how it is.
So let's talk about
adult development.
I can tell you that if you
compare adult development,
very little is understood
from 20 to 80.
Almost all the research is
taking something like college
students, and something
like 80-year-olds,
and comparing them.
So pretty much minimal
information is available about
everything between 20 and 80.
But we'll look at what we can.
And one of the things we'll talk
about for a moment is the
two kinds of studies we could
look at for development.
This could be about infants.
But we're going to talk
about adults.
Cross-sectional versus
longitudinal, so
cross-sectional is I look
at you as 20-year-olds.
I look at some 80-year-olds in
the Boston community and
compare them.
That's very different than
looking at you at 20 and
seeing you at 80.
Because that's much
more controlled.
That's you with everything
that's special and particular
about you at 20 and 80.
When you go get people who are
20-year-olds from one place
and 80-year-olds from another,
a cross-sectional , study,
that's going to have all
the differences that
go with those cohorts.
So what do we see in these
kinds of things?
So here's some measures.
You've seen this kind
of stuff before.
For things like working memory,
speed of processing,
and long-term memory.
Here's people in their '20s,
people in their '80s, a ski
scope of decline.
Here's things like knowledge
of vocabulary.
And that stays more steady,
so the crystallized fluid
distinction you've already
heard about before.
So what are the strengths and
limitations of cross-sectional
versus longitudinal studies.
So for cross-sectional studies,
they're fast.
If you're a scientist like a
graduate student who has to do
a Ph.D. thesis in a mere six or
seven years, you can go to
experiment with 20-year-olds
and 80-year-olds and have a
conclusion.
If you're a graduate student
who would have to test this
class of 20 and come back to you
in 60 years from now and
see how you're doing, that's
going to be slow progress.
So that's why an overwhelming
amount of evidence is
cross-sectional.
The problem with it
is cohort effects.
We discussed, for example, that
IQ scores go up year by
year throughout the world.
So you're not really comparing
equal things in terms of
educational opportunities,
nutrition, exposure to
information on the internet.
A 20-year-old and an 80-year-old
have lived through
different worlds.
So it's all mixed up in
the measurements.
Not just age, it's different
worlds that
people have lived in.
Longitudinal studies
are painfully slow.
They're more accurate, because
you're looking at change
within a person.
You're holding all the world
things constant.
You have one other weird
thing, which is you get
practice effects.
If you test somebody in the same
test, if you're 60 years
apart, you don't get much.
But if it's maybe three or four
years apart, you take a
test twice, you get
better at it.
So that's a problem with
longitudinal affects when you
retest somebody.
So there's been a few studies
that have looked at relatively
short-term longitudinal and
cross-sectional data.
And here's a ski slope on
the values of fluid
intelligence things.
And it's just made a bit milder
by a longitudinal
design, but not dramatically
different.
So it's not the case of
longitudinal studies.
People used to think oh, these
longitudinal studies are
overestimating that.
Especially if you're older,
you like that thought.
It's a messed up
study approach.
But unfortunately,
cross-sectional ones just
diminish the difference
a little bit.
So people have said,
though, there's
an interesting trade-off.
What's the trade-off, then--
I'll ask you for a moment--
between most of you
are like 18 to 22.
I'll bracket it 17 to 25.
Is that fair?
What advantage do you have
versus somebody in their
mid-'50s like me?
And what disadvantage do you
have in some global sense?
Oh.
That was painful.
The answer was you guys
are physically able.
All right.
That would be true.
There's not many Olympian
sprinters who
are in their mid-'50s.
How about in terms of
cognitive things?
So we just said, for speed
of mental processing,
it's good to be 20.
And then 30-year-olds
are a little slower.
40-year-olds, a little slower.
50, 60, 70, every decade a
little bit slower for speed of
mental processing.
But there's one thing
that's an advantage
with time for cognition.
What's the advantage?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Experience.
PROFESSOR: Experience.
Thank you.
Oh yes.
Yes.
Over time, you learn stuff,
especially stuff that you're
exposed to a lot.
So time is a trade-off
within adulthood.
You lose some speeded
capacities.
You gain some specific knowledge
or experience.
So they looked at studies
like these, air traffic
controllers in Canada.
And this is very relevant.
Especially now, air traffic
controllers are in the news
more than they want to be.
You've seen them?
Unfortunately, they're
napping.
They're playing movies,
some of them.
I'm sure it's a tiny minority.
But it's worrisome if you're a
member of the flying public.
So here's another question.
At what age should you tell
somebody, well, I think we
don't need you to be an air
controller anymore, because
you're not with it enough
for us to feel safe.
So people are probing
this all the time.
The average retirement age in
the US is 55, in Canada, 65.
Is one more correct
than the other?
And so here's what they found
when they looked at air
traffic controllers.
Age influences processing
speed but not task
performance.
So what we're thinking is older
people aren't better.
But they're not worse.
Maybe there's a trade-off
between speed and experience.
And it kind of evens out until
some age where it will no
longer even out.
118 pilots, 40 to 69, they
took place in flight
simulators and tested three
times across three years.
It's a longitudinal design
and a flight simulator.
The older pilots were worse the
first time they did it.
Now some time is passing.
But then they outperformed
the younger pilots in
years two and three.
That is, once they had some
experience with the new
situation, they could apply,
presumably, their prior
experience.
But the very first time they did
it when they have to use
their fluid intelligence to
figure out what's going on,
they were worse.
So you can see some trade-offs
between raw processing, speed,
and flexibility that goes with
the young adulthood and some
degree of knowledge
and expertise
that's gained over time.
There's trade-offs
on these things.
How about in memory, declarative
memory that we
talked about, every
day memory.
I'll show you in a moment.
There's mild, steady decline
in healthy aging severe in
Alzheimer's.
Implicit memory, we
talked about that.
It can be more steady
across ages.
But let me focus on explicit
memory, declarative memory.
We're going to figure out why
the projector is washing these
things out so much.
But here's a slide that
you don't have to see
very much to know.
Long-term memory performance
is going down quite sharply
year by year as you get older.
But here's something that was
a huge surprise from brain
imaging, a huge surprise.
And the thing that if you didn't
have brain imaging, you
wouldn't even conceive that
it could have existed.
So many studies have done
brain imaging as people
perform various kinds of tasks,
memory tasks in this
case, with young adults
and older adults.
And
what they found, unexpectedly,
was this.
Young adults would typically
activate one side of the
prefrontal cortex typically in
regards to whether it was
verbal or spatial.
So here's young adults mostly
on one side, mostly on one
side, mostly on one side,
mostly on one side.
Healthy older adults in good
health characteristically
turned on both sides of the
brain as they were performing
these memory tasks.
So you wouldn't have known
that if you didn't have
imaging, because who could
have thought about that?
So then there was a little bit
of a debate in the field with
the fact that adults were
turning on both sides of their
hemispheres whereas adults
were just picking one
or just using one.
Was that a good thing
or a bad thing?
So people said, well,
it's a bad thing.
Because maybe as you get
older, you lose your
specializations, and you're
using the wrong stuff.
It's as if I need
my physics book.
And I'm going to grab
my chemistry book.
Well, just grab your
physics book.
Just grab the right thing.
Why are you getting other stuff
that's not relevant that
could mess you up and
slow you down?
So some people said, you're
sort of losing the
specializations of peak
young adulthood.
You're leaking brain activity
in the wrong places.
It's yet another sad sign
of getting older.
Here's an alternative one.
Well, you get older.
But maybe you get some
compensatory mechanisms.
You realize at some level in
your brain that you can't do
what you could when
you were 20.
And you make up for that by
somehow using two sides of
your brain instead of one.
So that would be a good thing.
So how would you decide that?
How would you decide whether
using the two sides of your
brain when you're an older adult
is a helpful thing, part
of the solution to keeping your
cognition going, or is it
part of the problem of losing
long-term memory abilities as
you get older while
they're declining.
How would you decide that?
There's kind of an
easy answer.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
PROFESSOR: You what?
AUDIENCE: Like, split
their brains.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
It's a suggestion we should take
older people, split their
brains, and see how
they're doing.
Well, older people,
their long-term
memory is not that bad.
So here was the approach.
It seems reasonable.
They say amongst older people,
some people do better and
worse in terms of the memory.
Does better memory go with using
two sides or one side?
And what was found, and
here's one example.
Here's young people using one
side of their frontal cortex
as they perform a memory task.
Here's older people whose
memory was not so good.
memory was good.
And here's a similar finding.
So the suggestion was that older
people who used both
frontal cortices were actually
doing better.
They were having less of an
effective age on cognition.
So the answer seems to be,
it's a good thing.
And if you're older, you somehow
compensate for some of
the decrease in long-term
ability by applying more
neural systems to support
your performance.
Older adults are really
interested in this.
You are not.
In about 30 years,
you might be.
But older adults are really
interested in what can I do to
keep myself going?
Because I'm going to live to be
80, 90, or 100 with just a
little bit of luck.
How can I keep my quality
of life high in terms of
cognition and mental
abilities?
So one thing that people have
found is that, on average,
higher education is correlated
with-- and there's many
interpretations of this--
better cognitive abilities and
less likelihood of getting
Alzheimer's, or getting
Alzheimer's, if you're going
to get it, at an older age.
So that's kind of interesting.
It's good to go to college.
It's good to keep being educated
in some sense.
It doesn't have to be formal.
But formal education correlates
with that.
Now here was a surprise.
And now you tell
me what it is.
So how would that work?
How would sitting there and
listening to me really
carefully right now give you an
extra decade of cognitive
ability when you're 80?
All right, now I've got
your attention.
How would that work
biologically?
Is education kind of going in
your brain and saying, we're
knocking all these things in.
And we're keeping them here.
And we're not going to let
you have any injury when
you're 40 or 50.
How does that work?
So I'm going to tell you one
more piece of information,
which is this.
And you tell me what
you think.
So the other thing that we know
is there's evidence that
once you get the diagnosis of
Alzheimer's disease, then the
more educated you are, the
faster you decline.
And I don't think the story
is all done yet.
Because people are
complicated.
But this is the current
evidence.
So how do you interpret that?
So here's the interpretation.
The interpretation is more
education gives you more
mental tools, what people will
call cognitive reserve.
You have more things going for
you like maybe the ability to
use two hemispheres.
That will protect you as
something like some brain
injury happens over time, like
an Alzheimer's disease, or
other causes of slowed
or diminished
cognition in old age.
That will help you.
You have more tools with
which to keep operating
successfully.
But once Alzheimer's disease
become severe enough in the
brain that those tools are no
longer available to you, then
the more educated you are,
the more you plummet.
Because everything's done.
So we now know something--
and I'll just say
a word about this--
Alzheimer's disease-- and
this is compelling
evidence for this--
starts in your brain
about 15 years
before you get the diagnosis.
And it could be more
than that.
That's how far we can track
it back by brain imaging.
So if an adult is diagnosed
with Alzheimer's at 70,
somewhere around 55, something
has started that will
ultimately be injury enough
to lead to dementia and
Alzheimer's disease.
And that's why there's such
a big emphasis on early
identification.
Because it's very hard to
treat a brain that's
had a lot of injury.
You want to catch the
people at 55 or 60.
So we also know that lifelong
cognitively is good.
Conscientious, we talked
about that.
And here, again,
comes exercise.
So they took a study.
This is now a random assignment
study, finally a
full on experiment, where they
took sedentary people, people
who were not exercising over 60,
and assigned them to two
groups, an aerobic training
group who did walking and
swimming, so some really
exercise, and non-aerobic
group who did toning
and stretching.
So they thought they
were special.
They were active.
But they weren't doing
the aerobic exercise.
And they didn't do it a
phenomenal amount of time, an
hour a day, a few times
a week for months.
It's not a brutal exercise
schedule.
What happens?
It's kind of amazing
what happened.
These are healthy people
but not very active.
What's shown here in the red
bars are the cognitive
performances after the
exercise of the
healthy older people.
And blue bars are the people
who did the stretching and
toning, not the aerobic
exercise.
So very substantial gains in
cognitive abilities from a few
months of moderate exercise.
And in the brain, both by
functional MRI and by
structural MRI, in gray matter,
and white matter,
physically measurable changes
in the brain for the group
that did the aerobic exercise
a couple times a week for a
few months compared to
the group that did
the less active exercises.
That's amazing.
The brain changes.
Cognition changes.
Again, no pill you can pop.
And you're making new neurons in
your dentate gyrus to boot.
So all of us want
the easy out.
But exercise is the most
compelling story for keeping
your brain optimized
that we know.
Now here's a remarkable thing.
Exercise, we kind of get.
Actually, if you think about
it, we don't know the
mechanism at all.
I mean, you're running
around like this.
Now how is that pushing up your
neurons in your brain?
But here's something
very psychological
that's kind of stunning.
And at first, I almost didn't
believe it when I read it.
But there's been a few
other studies that
have supported this.
We often think, well, exercise
is something real.
Attitudes, even in a psychology
course, attitudes,
they're just attitudes.
So look at this.
And then you can think
about this.
So they looked in a longitudinal
study of over 400
in the Baltimore Longitudinal
Study of Aging.
They started under 50.
But they kept going with them.
They gave them a questionnaire
on attitudes about aging.
So they said, are older people,
for example, more
absent-minded or less
intelligent?
And some people say,
oh my gosh.
Older people are very
absent-minded.
They're very less intelligent.
Other people think it's
just a milder think.
People vary in their estimates
of how severe these changes
are in old age.
Then they measured something
very concrete and real, the
number of cardiovascular events,
like stroke or heart
attack, over the
next 38 years.
So this is a real physical
measurement.
This isn't an attitude.
How powerful is an attitude?
Well, it's kind of stunning,
unbelievably
powerful in some ways.
We don't know if it's the
attitude or something
correlated.
But here's the percent with
strokes or heart attacks.
Here's the people who had
negative age stereotypes.
And here's the people who had
positive age stereotypes.
So one always has to be
worried about the
chicken and egg issue.
Maybe if you had a lot of
strokes and heart attacks,
you're not so optimistic
about your old age.
But they were measuring these
things at the beginning, they
were very similar.
So they weren't starting
out with
different health problems.
So something about attitudes
seems to chip in to the most
core aspects of physical
health.
But none of us understand
the mechanism.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't family
history have a
lot to do with that?
PROFESSOR: So the question is
how about family history?
It could be mixed into that.
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's a very good.
Then it's not just
attitudes, right?
Or it could be not
attitudes it all.
And here's the concept.
That regardless of your age--
but age is one of the most
powerful pieces of the story--
when your time is limited,
people focus on social goals
related to emotional meaning and
emotional satisfaction and
less related to knowledge
acquisition.
That depending on the moment of
your life on average, when
you're in adolescence, and
you're in college and graduate
school, and you're beginning
your residency, or becoming a
junior partner at a law firm,
you're at an age of huge
information acquisition.
What you want to know is what
do I need to know to do
something important,
significant,
valuable in my life?
You're sitting here acquiring
knowledge.
College is four years of
acquiring knowledge in terms
of classrooms and majors.
You guys do other things too.
But the number one mission is
acquire that knowledge.
Now when you get older, you
don't really want so much
information anymore.
And maybe what you're much more
interested in is how you
regulate your feelings, how
positive can you make your
life, not by being adventurous,
taking risks, and
all this kind of stuff,
but by finding
a way towards happiness.
And I'm going to show you
a bunch of research that
suggests that young adulthood
is full about acquisition of
information through adventure.
And old age, on average you're
focused to regulate your
emotions in positive ways.
And so sometimes people
will call that wisdom.
Although, you could just say
it's different things for
different ages are desirable.
And part of the support came
from the following result,
which has been found many,
many, many times.
But it was kind of stunning when
it was first reported.
So this is where people were
asked, how happy are you?
Are you satisfied
with your life?
So here's a younger adults,
18 to 50 basically.
About half of them said they're
very satisfied.
But it zooms up if
you're older.
How many people are satisfied
with their standard of living?
40 if you're younger.
60 if you're older.
Frequency of depression,
for example, never.
Let's pick often.
It's higher for younger
people.
They have more frequent thoughts
about suicide.
By every measure you can make,
if we give you a questionnaire
like this, on average, for
20-year-olds or 30-year-olds,
you would report more
unhappiness than older people,
on average.
Of course, it varies.
But that's kind of a surprise
maybe or not.
And everybody has found that.
No, not a surprise?
AUDIENCE: I mean, just because
they report something, doesn't
mean that's the way it is.
PROFESSOR: Ah well we'll come
back to this again.
Yes.
Just because you say
you're happier
doesn't mean you're happier.
We don't have a better
way than that though.
We can't say, oh, you
think you're happy.
But you'd be so happy if
you were at Caltech.
You'd be just so happy.
I'm a brain measurer.
So I like objective measures.
I think if a person tells
you they're happy,
they probably are.
There are certain moments,
I know, when
people tell you that.
Well, we'll see.
Who knows?
I agree with you.
It's a concern.
So here's the thought, that
motivation and goals are set
by temporal context.
At times, they're perceived
as limited.
And all this will come that the
older you get, the more
you focus on the positive
things in the world.
And what makes you happy is to
focus on positive things and
ignore the negative.
So how true might this
be experimentally?
So they had students-- ah, this
is really washed out--
capture these special moments,
this same ad.
And this one says, "Capture the
special moments." And this
one says, "Capture the
unexplored world."
So if you're an information
seeker, which is better? the
unexplored world or the special
moments, which is better?
The unexplored world, right?
You're a 20-year-old.
Unexplored Is awesome.
Young people prefer this ad.
Older people prefer the
special moments.
And by special moments, we mean
emotionally satisfying.
Right?
OK.
Here's another one.
They show you up pictures of
a positive and negative
expression.
It flashes away.
And there's a dot left.
If the dot appears on the
right, you push your
right-hand button.
If the dot appears on
the left, you push
the left-hand button.
It's simply pushing to a dot.
But if the dot is in the place
where you just saw, either a
negative or a neutral face.
And what they find is for
younger people, they're about
as fast whether the dot appears
where the neutral or
negative face was.
They don't really care.
For the older people, they're
much faster if the dot appears
where the positive face
had just been.
As if their attention was locked
to the positive face.
Oh, the dot appears there.
I'm ready to go.
Locked on the positive face
if the dot appears here.
You go, whoa, whoa, whoa.
You shift your attention.
And that takes extra time.
So you're locked to the positive
when you see a
positive and a negative face.
Here's another one where you're
doing positive and
negative car options,
things that are good
or bad about a car.
This line goes up.
This line goes down.
Younger people focus more on the
negative options relative
to older people who focus more
on the positive options.
Here's another one.
You show pictures of happy
scenes, or neutral scenes, are
negative scenes.
This is a graveyard.
Young people's memory for
positive, negative, and
neutral things, they remember
emotional things better.
Let's go to the older people.
Look at this line way up here.
That's memory for the
positive scenes.
And here's the negative
scenes.
Do you see the focus on the
positivity and the sort of
lack of interest in the
negative stuff?
For young people, equally
interesting if it's positive
or negative.
For older people, much more
interesting, and sticking in
your memory if it's positive.
And not sticking in your memory
if it's negative.
So one of the big questions
is, is this simply about
getting older?
And I'm going to ask you to
think back, if I can, to your
last days in high school, your
last days in high school.
For those last days--
and I'm sure it will vary
depending on your experience
in different ways--
were you primarily interested
in getting that last little
bit of information about
US history or calculus?
I mean, you might have been.
That could have been the
critical bit of information
that will make college
work out.
Or did you have a sudden--
and it's kind of embarrassing
when you're 16, 17, 18--
enhanced sense of nostalgia?
Oh, this is the last time the
three of us, or the six of us,
or the eight of us, or the two
of us will be together.
Then we're spreading across
the world to go
to different colleges.
Nobody had that feeling?
OK.
It's kind of embarrassing
when you're 18.
Because you're not supposed
to say that kind of stuff.
And it will happen to you at the
end the college for most
of you most of the time.
I remember senior year, it crept
up on us in college.
And we started college.
Oh my gosh.
This is the last year
we're together.
And it seemed very emotionally
important.
So age or time.
So is it simply age?
Or is it time?
So they did experiments where
they asked people, are you
focusing on adventure
and content?
Or are you focusing on emotion
and satisfaction?
When you're about to move from
one city to another, people
waned to spend time
with people they
really cared about.
And they were not interested
in getting new information.
Two more tragic studies, if
people are near death, and
they're asked this question,
of course time with people,
not acquiring information.
But here's another one,
inner-city gangs study in Los
Angeles, inner-city gangs
involved in violence are much
more interested in time with
people than in information.
And partly that goes with what
is viewed from the outside.
Sometimes this kind of insane
loyalty that inner-city gang
members have for one another is
because they're so focused
given their situation on this
relations with the other
people in their group compared
to everything that's rational
about a safe growing up.
And, tragically, you know if you
ask a member of inner-city
gangs how long they think
they'll live, they often tell
you not very long.
I'm counting on not
living very long.
So it's not whether you're
20, or 60, or 80.
It's how long you sense
time is in front of
you, a temporal horizon.
Here's one study that
I had a hand in.
We took older and younger people
and put them inside an
MRI and show them positive,
neutral,
and negative pictures.
Here's a couple different
points.
When they said, how intense
is this picture?
Look at younger people.
The positive, neutral, and the
negative are really intense.
This goes down.
So the older people, as they see
the pictures, experienced
by their own report, the
negative pictures as being
less intense.
They're sort of downplaying
the negative.
And if we asked their memory,
here's younger people.
Positive, and negative things,
neutral things, same for
positive and negative.
Look at older people, much
more focused in memory,
retaining in memory
the positive and
not so much the negative.
And if we look at their
amygdala, which we know is a
structure that's essential for
how emotion modulates the
formation of memory, here's
young people.
Here's a positive picture.
Here's a negative picture.
Here's a neutral picture.
So emotion counts.
Positive and negative count
about the same.
Look at older people.
Here's positive, and
here's negative.
So this partly addresses the
question for some people.
Are older people pretending
they're positive?
Well, it doesn't
look like that.
This is their amygdala as
they're looking at it.
I don't know if their
amygdala can pretend
to look at the positive.
So here's the good
news for you.
What will happen as you get
older, on average, is that for
whatever reason it happens-- and
we don't really know why--
you will focus more and
more on the positive
things in your life.
And you'll feel better
for that, on average.
So that's the kind of
quiet satisfaction.
Now I'm focusing on
the positive.
That's the zen satisfaction.
Let's talk about fantastic
satisfaction, reward system.
When you really want to do
something, because it's going
to feel so wonderful,
the reward system.
So let me tell you a little bit
about what we understand
about that.
It involves dopamine as the
critical neurotransmitter.
It starts in the ventral
tegmental
area of your brainstem.
And that projects to something
called the nucleus accumbens,
an inferior portion of
the basal ganglia.
And this is reward central.
If you love something from
opera, to chocolate, to video
games, this turns on.
Every experiment that people
have ever done shows in humans
if something really turns
you on, this area
really gets turned on.
What's more powerful for us
than what we find deeply
emotionally rewarding?
This is that rewards system.
And the dopamine runs
from there.
And look at how cells respond.
I'm going to show you an example
from monkeys where we
can look at single cells.
And then brain imaging,
back to people.
So here's the experiment
with monkeys.
And there's a message in this
that's both biologically true
and compelling about
human life.
So what's biologically true in
science what's compelling
about life is a story.
So here's the experiment.
The monkey sits there and gets
various cues, different visual
things that tell them
what's coming up.
Let's pretend this is a cue
that's something wonderful is
coming up, highly
desired food.
So they're recording
electrically why
the animal sees this.
There's waiting for what we call
the anticipation period.
And now here comes the reward.
And here's something sort of
deep, I think, about reward,
and learning, and people,
and things like this.
So here's the neurons firing.
This is the sum of the neurons
firing in the ventral
tegmental area.
So right now they're
just sitting there.
Oops, here comes the reward.
And boom, dopamine
is released.
The dopaminergic cells are
firing like crazy.
They're getting food
they really want.
We're thrilled.
We're hungry, and we're getting
something delicious.
Not much more rewarding
can happen when
you're really hungry.
Now they predict the arrival
with the cue that you saw, a
meaningless stimulus.
And look what happens.
When do these neurons fire?
Not for the food arriving, but
for the visual signal that
predicts the food will come.
What's delicious for the brain
is the anticipation of
something that's rewarding.
And this morning when I was
thinking about this lecture, I
was thinking.
You might say this.
Think about experiences
you've had that you've
looked forward to.
And almost the most delicious
part, you might say, is the
anticipation of something
delightful.
Often the event itself is more
mixed and anticlimactic than
you would've thought.
Is that fair?
I think there's nothing better
like I'm anticipating
something wonderful.
And the event can
be wonderful.
But often it's a little
more complicated.
That anticipation is like
pure joy, because you're
dopaminergic system is
firing freely away.
And it protests also.
So you get the visual
signal that, oh, the
reward's coming up.
Here it is.
Here comes the food.
The food doesn't come.
Look at the silence.
These cells are protesting
because they didn't get what
they expected to get.
So it's very compelling that the
reward in you occurs not
even so much for the reward
itself, but the anticipation
of the reward is where it's
biologically occurring when
you can anticipate and count
on it correctly.
So, in humans, it's harder to
deliver-- not impossible--
food in a scanner.
So a very simple thing is done
for a reward, which is
offering people money.
So in a given trial on a
scanner, you might see a
meaningless cue like this.
But you learn that this box
predicts that at the end of
this trial--
you do many trials--
you're going to get $1.00.
Another one might be $0.10.
Another one they might
take away $1.00.
So this is like a
good one to get.
I'm going to get $1
just sitting here.
I'm going to get $1.
It's not huge.
It's not the biggest reward
in the world.
But it's something for
just laying in the
scanner doing nothing.
And here's what happens.
Your nucleus accumbens gets
activated, where dopamine
flows from the ventral tegmental
area when you
anticipate a reward.
This is not when the
reward comes.
This is when you're anticipating
the reward.
Here's another picture.
It's most powerful
for when people
anticipate a gain, a reward.
And it's less responsive when
people anticipate a loss.
So it's about gains.
Then the same system projects to
the inferior parts of your
frontal lobe.
So now we're moving into
the neocortex.
And that part of the brain
seems to respond most
powerfully if you
get the reward.
So this is really interesting,
a part of your brain that
responds to the anticipation,
the
dopaminergic reward system.
And then another part of their
brain that responds not
whether you anticipate it.
But sometimes they trick you.
They say we're going
to give you $1.
And then they go, oops.
We're not giving it to you.
This part of the brain seems to
register the receipt of the
reward or not.
So there's a separation of the
brain between the anticipation
of the reward and the response
to whether you get
the reward or not.
Older people, when they look
at these kinds of similar
reward paradigms, they're less
responsive to potential loss
but equally responsive
to potential
gain as young adults.
So that's exactly responding to
positive things and showing
less of a response to potential
negative things.
So let's switch to
adolescents.
We're going to focus on
adolescents now mostly for the
next 10 minutes.
You just got through that.
So let's reflect back for the
last couple of years.
And they make the experiments
because they want to put
children into a little
bit more of a vivid.
Here's pirates.
Here's not much reward.
Here's some reward.
Here's a lot of reward
in the scanner.
And your children are
adolescents or young adults.
And they look in the
nucleus accumbens.
This is that reward region.
And look who's firing
like crazy?
Adolescents, teenagers.
But they're not firing like
crazy in the frontal cortex.
So this is very speculative.
These are partly just
wide stories.
But one hypothesis is this.
And we're going to say in a
minute more about this.
Adolescence is a really
interesting period.
Because it's not only when
you're deciding who you are in
the world in many ways
independently.
It's also, worrisomely for
parents, grandparents,
cousins, siblings, the period
in life when people are most
likely to put themselves
at great risk.
And one version of that is that
the subcortical reward
areas are developing way faster
than the cortical areas
that control and regulate
your behavior.
This goes with the stereotype
which is probably as unfair as
any other stereotype of the
out of control teenager.
But imagine if it were true
that your reward system is
very turned up.
And your cortical control system
were not yet caught up
to the adult level.
Well, that would make you a
little bit more likely to do
adventuresome things.
Because the reward
is powerful.
And the control of your thoughts
about how to approach
or reject that reward
are less powerful.
So here's some things
to think about.
And people worry about
for adolescents.
40% of adult alcoholics report
having initial alcoholism
between 15 and 19.
Between 16 and 20, both sexes
are twice as likely to be in
accidents than drivers between
20 and 50, twice the
accidental rate.
Adolescents are more likely to
engage in impulsive sexual
behavior and multiple
partners.
Annually, three million
adolescents contract a sexual
transmitted disease.
So lots of things that are risky
behaviors occur with
high frequency in a demonstrable
way, on average,
among adolescents.
Young kids don't drive yet.
20-year-olds are a bit more
mature in their driving.
So part of this is, again,
attitudinal.
Here's a question that people
were asked about future
perspectives.
They were asked, I would rather
save my money for a
rainy day than spend it on
something fun right now.
In your 20s, a little bit.
That's growing.
You'll keep the dollar.
But the younger you are in your
teenage years, the more
like who wants to wait.
Let's do it now.
So moving from something fun
to something experimental,
let's put together a
couple last things.
So here's a thing we did before
several times in this
class, creating false
memories.
And you remember the way they
create false memories in the
laboratory is they pick a word
they don't present to you,
like sweet.
Then they ask many students to
say what words go with that
word, like sour, or
candy, or sugar?
They present you this list.
And then they test
you for this word
that was not presented.
And people often imagine
incorrectly that they heard or
saw this word.
We've done that a
couple of times.
It's a way to show
illusory memory.
And the way we understand
it is basically this.
Your memory, your mind, mostly
thinks about the essence of
things, not the details
of things.
The essence of things was
everything is sweet.
The details were the specific
words in the list.
So let's look at older adults
versus younger adults,
80-year-olds versus 20-year-olds
and exactly this
experiment.
Older adults have many
more false memories.
And they perform less well.
So to a scary extend, the
healthy 70-year-olds, here's
their real memories.
Here's their false memories.
It's dead even.
Here's young people having lots
of false memories, but
not as many as older
people, and having
more correct memories.
So older adults have more
false memories, because
they're encoding the
gist a lot, but
they're losing the specifics.
Does that make sense?
And you're really vulnerable
to false memories.
Children, you might think,
well children,
what do they know?
Children have less false
memories than you do.
You would have less false
memories at age five than you
would right now, which
is kind of amazing.
If you didn't do the experiment,
you'd imagine
children would be totally
confused.
They'd get a big
list of words.
Was sweet on the list?
I don't know.
Yeah, sure.
A five-year-old does better than
a seven, does better than
an 11-year-old, does better
than a 20-year-old.
Why?
Why does a five-year-old have
less false memories under the
circumstances?
Well, we understand that to be
the price of having a mind
that understands
a lot of gist.
As you become older, you
understand what's important,
what counts.
It's not the little details.
It's the big concepts.
So here's an example of, for
example, how well people can
relate words across sentences.
And that grows from
six to nine.
And that's what we want.
You don't want to read
word, word, word.
You want to say, what's the
point of the sentence?
That process of saying, I don't
care about the detail.
I care about the concept, the
gist of the concept, it's like
the chess players.
You shed the specific
details to gain the
overall knowledge advantage.
But the five-year-old is not
making the big picture.
They're just getting
the little details.
So they're less prone to
the illusory memories.
We can't see that.
But this is just showing that
when it comes to organizing
memories, you see that develop
across a childhood.
Last couple of things.
Because when I heard this a few
years ago at a conference,
I was so surprised by
these findings.
And I've been around long enough
that i don't get as
surprised as often
as I used to.
But it's kind of really
interesting.
It's a total twist.
And you can make a judgment
call about how
to interpret it.
But here's the experiments
and the data.
So, again, we have this picture
that everybody likes
because it fits with the
stereotype, which is the
teenager out of control.
Their dopamine is going up.
And they're saying, let's do a
lot of inappropriate things.
Because it will be rewarding.
I know everybody's against it.
So that's the stereotype.
And probably there's something
true about that.
Literally, in the brain
imaging, it
looks somewhat true.
But let's think about
this for a moment.
You're going to be
good at this.
If line a--
these are lines-- is longer than
b, and line b is longer
than line c, is a
longer than c?
Yes.
All right.
This is MIT.
Now answer this question
truly.
Think about it for a moment.
Person a is a friend
or person b.
So let's pretend you're person
b and your friend was a.
You're also a friend with c.
Are a and c likely
to be friends?
Let's think about this.
Is it mathematically transitive
like this one?
No.
Let's think about
it for a moment.
In your experience through life,
on average, are your
friends mostly kind of going
to like each other?
Kind of, not all the
time, but kind of?
Yeah, probably.
Because if one person likes you,
and another person likes
you, you share interests.
You share background to a
certain extent, in a loose
statistical way.
It's not definitive like this.
So let's take a look at what
happens when you ask you two
questions to grades
one through four.
OK, these kids are just
making mistakes.
And they're getting smarter.
But look at this one go
up just like that.
So we can say this is a growth
in logical ability.
This is a growth in your
everyday sense that I hang out
with a certain kind of person.
Maybe they like football.
Maybe they like skating.
Maybe they like psychology.
but that's the group I tend
to hang out with.
And, on average, if I have a
friend, it's because we share
some interests, or
style of being.
And if I have another friend,
we probably share that too.
So more than chance, they
might like each other.
So this is this idea that you
can separate out what you
might call purely logical
analysis of things versus a
growth of social experience,
basically.
So the last three
slides or so.
You remember this from a bit
back, from a prior example.
We said there's a framing
heuristic.
People are risk averse
for gains.
But they're risk-taking
for losses.
If we said here's a program.
We did this before.
If Program A is adopted,
200 people are saved.
Or here's 400 people will
die out of 600.
That's the same statement.
But because this is stated
as a gain, people
usually like this.
Because this is stated
as a loss, people
usually don't like this.
Adults are risk averse for
gains, and they're risk-taking
for losses.
If something looks like
a loss, roll the dice.
If something looks like it's
going to work out, go with it,
even though numerically,
these are identical.
You can't see this.
I can tell you.
It's not present in
preschoolers or second graders.
Preschoolers or second graders,
when you give them
these kinds of problems, they
don't show the asymmetry for
losses and gains.
That's something that
happens over time.
And it's not a logical one.
Logically, it should be that.
So in that weird sense, the
preschooler is more logical
than you and I, more logical
than you and I. Because
there's no reason to be
statistically different for
losses and gains.
That's purely an attitudinal
emotional perspective.
First of all, you can hear
the information-seeking.
Let's check it out.
That's kind of interesting,
swimming with sharks.
I can assure you 70-year-olds
are not going to go, hey, that
can be kind of interesting.
They're going, no!
Terrible idea!
Don't do it!
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Were they asked
in a group collectively?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You see some peer influence.
Yeah.
And that doesn't happen with
adolescents, right?
They do this.
They go, oh my gosh.
These are these teenagers who
are going to go do all these
things, and get horrible sexual
diseases, and drive
while they are impaired.
And that's just the beginning
of their weekend.
Because they're not going to
follow all the advice that we
gave them for years, and years,
and years, and years,
at home and in school.
So here's the flip on this.
And just think about
it for a moment.
It's complicated.
Swimming with sharks, the adults
say, you don't have to
tell me any more.
It's a bad idea.
The gist is sharks, bad.
I don't even need to hear
the rest of the story.
Adolescents start to
weigh the factors.
We'd be safer in a group.
Is it dark or night outside?
How shallow is the water?
And you can say, well, it's
kind of ridiculous.
But it's not totally
ridiculous.
Because when we talk about
danger, those are some of the
things you might start
to think about.
So by this analysis, having
unprotected sex.
Adults, bad, bad, bad.
OK?
I mean really bad.
Adolescents, well, let's
think about this.
What's the gain?
Well, we hear that sex is
highly pleasurable.
What's the loss?
All these things everybody's
telling us.
What's the odds, purely
statistically, that for a
single, sexual experience, you
will have the pleasure of sex,
but you will end up with
a terrible disease?
What's the odds for
one outing?
What do you think?
Here's the complexity.
Some people argue that
adolescents are actually more
accurate in their assessment
of risk, not
wise in their choice.
Do you understand the point?
They're actually doing the
calculations, whereas adults
just go, sharks bad.
Sexually transmitted
diseases, avoid.
You're not parsing through the
exact odds and circumstances,
the trade-offs between
exploration and pleasure and
responsibility and safety.
You just have the gist,
the line, that's it.
That's my wisdom that
I've gotten.
Sharks, bad.
Sexually transmitted
disease, bad.
That's it.
And these teenagers are kind
of curiously thinking about
what are the factors.
And you could say, it's
not the best analysis.
But you could say it's
almost more rational.
Just like the older adults will
make more gist errors in
memory, they will be more
emotional in their
avoidance of risk.
So it's very complicated.
It's not just dopamine
flushing.
It's also in the brain.
It's also something about how
risk is perceived at different
ages and what information
is available to you.
All right.
Thanks very much.